how do you describe software engineering
to dates about them getting immediately
port help me what's poppin good morning
I hope you guys are having a fantastic
Thursday and today I'm just gonna get a
few honey nears to answer some of these
questions that you asked me on the
previous vlog if you haven't seen that
it's this one
a lot of good questions and hopefully
good answers from us
one more thing I just want to say thank
you so much for 2500 subscribers
Wow like yeah we grew pretty fast so I'm
pretty happy about that it's all thanks
to you guys so thank you so much I also
talked about the air pod giveaway at the
end of this video so stick around
alright so it's time to go to work you
[Music]
slacker
I know you are want to make a video of
me can you answer some CS pressures for
me what's the essence CS advice
questions you have some RAM come come
come with them let's go let's go let's
go let's go let's pop in dude dude I
want to make a video of me no really
come on just answer some questions I
need engineers to ask let's go all right
what like you're my friends you know
what's up guys alright so remember I did
a Q&A before or I asked you to do a Q&A
on my last video when I had adult
subscribers now I'm going to answer them
so let's go through it okay first
question
by Omar Santiago it's on for engineer an
easy major it is for me what do you mean
why doesn't make any sense okay so in
Waterloo there is a software engineering
major and it is it's it's not as easy as
the computer science major which is what
I did next question so we have
engineering and also we have like
sciences
so I took a Bachelor of Science in
computer science and then most people
can get an engineering degree in soccer
chair hurricane ask how'd you get how
would you learn to get so good at
breakdancing is not good that's not true
but yeah I was just born like oh sure
this question so long oh there's so many
question okay Jake Nicole asked I find
Ted quite intimidating so channels
deafening and I okay thanks so one do
tech companies care about which
university you went to or is it really
down to internships and experience when
starting in the industry I don't think
that your school matters too much but it
doesn't matter in terms of like what
companies might come to my career fairs
its how big your career is
but like probably like at your schools
smaller you might have to put them where
I've hurt them too I get the impression
that tech people are quite busy and I do
see some people coding on public
transportation it's a house life outside
of tech job well my life is great but
that's because I'm a data scientist and
we don't do it coding as much but yeah I
don't know like outside of tech but for
me I just do a lot of videos lately so I
don't I think work with balance is
pretty good just that there are ups and
downs
I guess so sometimes I think it's like
really busy and sometimes a lot of
downtime so I don't think we're always
busy how long does it take to learn a
language before being qualified to use
it for work I don't think you even need
to learn a language before you're
qualified because just don't tell them
that you don't know it you'll be fine
know like if you want a job just tell
them you know that language and then
once you get the interview that's when
you learn all right I love which
languages you know and they'll let you
kown at that language and once you get
to the company you can learn whatever
language they use yeah that's what I
meant I mean yeah you could learn the
language on the job but yeah are you
still doing the regular vlogs if you
mean my startup series
yes episode 3 is coming out soon I'm
probably gonna publish it February 1st
so yeah be able to look up for that
favorite music kpop alright
another long-ass question all right
number one how do you write your
university experience at Waterloo it was
great - really selling your school right
here it was fine lots of internship is
really good a lot of friends yes courses
are pretty easy how did you start learn
to code I went to college and there was
a coding class
oh well coz because my brother took the
CS constant so then he told me that
there's lots of money in tension so then
I started doing tap what inspired you to
become a programmer yeah I was riveted
so I want what our TV shows you like to
watch what do you like to watch you like
how'd you know what's your favorite city
in the entire world Seoul Korea boobs
what advice would you give to a teenager
trying to make it out there in a tech
world make sure you do want to come to
tech before you decide cuz you're still
a teenager and yeah I would I would also
suggest you to get a girlfriend before
coming to college because I guess harder
in tech in tacky
yes it's should are dirt any downsides
to working in tech I don't know you just
have too much money and like yeah so
lack of diversity that's here that's one
problem like I'm trying to make you know
artistic friends but you know none of
these people are artistic so how do you
know alright next CherryBerry ask what
colors are under beds okay real question
do you actually intend to start a
startup ok real answer I'm on a TN visa
so I'm not allowed to to start my own
business or have any other income other
than my actual job right now sasquatch
cats watch ask Lamar I love your sense
of humor and personality thanks alright
your videos for myself it was the
question my question is what tips advice
would you give to a high schooler trying
to become a sweet in the future any dues
or don'ts
love your videos finally I hate it
Oh why'd you why'd you end up coming
back down cuz I took it again in college
I always suggest doing a lot of side
projects like just making a website for
yourself and internships not my
schoolers have internships of course
your internship before you gonna call it
just take that stubborn oh yeah sure
don't get a girlfriend look at me now
alright your videos providing your
videos provide so much detailed
information about interns I absolutely
love it
question how do you compare the work and
tech companies and want finance and can
you interview your brother why does my
brother always get the spotlight in
quant I guess the biggest difference is
that quandary searchers are first
citizens but tech companies suffer
engineers are first citizens Jesse Chan
what is one thing about tech industry
programming that annoys you when is
something you wish you could change
about the industry love your videos keep
it up thank you guys for emails going
into tech it's pretty different there's
a lot of pain points obviously because
of the gender gender I wanna say no
probably like lack of diversity that's
gender for example during one of my
internships I was the only girl in the
team of 10 engineers and that's pretty
hard to deal with especially culturally
like they like things that you might may
not necessarily like and it's hard to
fit in but those are just one of those
things that are improving slowly and
that's why we need more girls to come
into tech so that that kind of change
Congrats are a milestone bro question
for you
someone who seems quite busy on a daily
basis what would you say are some of
your keys to productivity in top
oh no way keys to productivity and
application goals hmm I guess manage
your time I mean slowly I guess one test
I found the most useful it is start
using a calendar and time box your stuff
you know to make sure that you don't go
overboard
Kevin Walter asked can you get a job at
a big company in the USA as a German
graduate students yeah probably you just
have to apply into like a big company or
any company that would sponsor you and
they'll give you like the h-1b visa and
you could stay exhort its ass when
applying for your first tech job how do
you know when you're ready at what point
do you just go for it and and what
advice do you have to be ready for a
first-time job you're always ready yeah
you're always ready okay just believe in
yourself just apply just apply because
like if you fail then okay you know
you're not ready to but like what is it
like working with other professionals
our engineers oh really
you guys not a passion it's very
demanding you know they're very
professional ya know it's the same thing
it's not working with normal introduced
I guess I don't know is the same as
working you know in a school project
kind of do you have any pieces of a
device such as things to avoid in the
workplace as in asking dumb questions
Wow come on man there's no such thing as
a dumb question
well like you should always shouldn't
just ask everything you should so like
trying to figure it out on your own and
if after like
who is your current favorite music
artist black Oh what would you say what
is your skincare routine before moving
on from wish it's not that good it's
what's because what is there okay well I
can tell you mine
first you use toner then you use our
like face wash now you use own and then
you wait wait okay fine okay face wash
and tone okay clearly I don't do it I
actually just put water my face and then
I put moisturizer yeah I know then wash
my face to be like yeah wait what else
is call it the mask yeah okay what's
your favorite part about your current
job I think my favorite part is to
people that were like can you do it
again poof like more genuine my favorite
part another great video Jolla yes I can
see you definitely hitting those 10 K
before the summer anyways one question
are you actually working right now oh
it's so what tech do you work on your
daily life so I'm I should to get a
scientist and I work for a decently
large company Silicon Valley
Simon fallin pass what are some
important attributes you like to see in
a fellow sovereign generic
well I mean it's not like I'm a manager
or anything really matter but I mean I
usually like engineers who also have
empathy meaning they actually know what
they're building and who they're
building it for so that you know they
care more about the private lending
build stuff also when your coat doesn't
suck pineapple ask kit as one of my
heart is set on iOS developer well the
answer this question to be and I was the
developer that's okay wait I don't I
don't know what that means
I think it's one major to a major I was
like what is the maybe it'll be better
this one first see estimate heart the
iOS developer por que por que tengo
mucho dinero how do you describe
software engineering to dates about them
getting immediately important help me I
never tell them at first that myself or
engineer or I work in tech so just say
that you get to build products that's
sure yeah if you're in a big tech
company or like a popular one like
snapchat you could just say oh I work
for snapchat and then
[Music]
yeah I guess I'll know describe your
hobbies instead all right David Kwan ask
great videos looking to get in the tech
industry myself on my first quantum four
systems and design engineering at
Waterloo right now oh well nice a fellow
Waterloo kid so these videos help a lot
this is pretty general but people always
say to do projects and I was wondering
what sorts of things to do that will
give good experience or good she don't
like like it's fair but I don't like
people who only do projects because it
looks good on their resume because I
don't know cuz first of all it doesn't
even seem like you care about it but I
mean if you really have to then ya
probably do some web projects for stacks
just to show that you know every part of
the stack but yeah I mean I would
recommend you to do something that you
enjoy and you have fun because you'd
probably make it better anyways if you
do like doing it alright okay so thank
you so much for all of these questions I
hope this was helpful for you guys yeah
I guess I'll see you later back at home
peace alright so I just want to say big
thanks to all my friends who
participated in the video if you want to
follow them on Instagram you can I'll
just put them down below also I want to
say earpods
the contest is still running it's gonna
run until January 30th and here it is
these are the air pods that you will
receive ooh the contest is not over so
it's not too late to participate all you
have to do is you follow me on Instagram
and on Twitter so that will give you two
entries to the contest so for the
questions I did not answer so so sorry I
just didn't have enough time and it
would make the video too long but if you
message me on Instagram I will answer
you and I'll probably give a better
answer and a serious answer so it's
probably even better if you ask me
once again thank you so much for
watching you guys are the best thank you
for the support I just want to say that
you know because of you guys it really
pushes me to make the first
entertainment channel for tech people by
tech people I just want to say again
this is really important to me but I
just want to make tech more open and
accessible and entertaining so if you
liked what you saw don't forget to
subscribe and also press the
notification button so that you can get
notified whenever I go live or a new
video comes out anyways thank you so
much peace
[Music]